okay so now I'm gonna my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I
[Music]
happy Halloween everything last year
Shrek you had to endure hours on a
depressant maybe it was easy I was not
done in like four hours so nothing
compared to Shrek four hours this year
she cheated all day like it was crazy
she was sitting in the storefront
getting ready for like 12 hours I was
only four so it was yeah you're like I
asked for employed costume that's
actually taking your last time what is
her costume so I was on a mission on his
face my goodness really you it's not
earlier you get that like for you I mean
I was getting the scoop from Tom he only
took four hours this year he was like
this is a piece of cake and a Bears in
distress I totally lost track of time
today I don't even know how long the
distant for me to do today
I started at ten and it's
it's like after 11 or so yeah 11:30 yeah
so it took like more than 12 hours a day
but you look incredible and I gotta say
whoa you are so in character and I can
smell you it's probably my armpits I'm
sorry it's a little bit of everything
it's my armpit it's the glue hi it's the
page is everything yeah okay tell us the
inspiration behind this year's costume
because you need inspiration my dad so I
was an omission in outer space looking
for a new planet because we almost
destroyed ours right so looking for a
new planet for the humans to live on and
I found her and brought her back and
thought you know she might have some
useful information for us you for
showing off some major curves tonight I
am are you enjoying the air I am I love
my booty a lot finally I can turn I can
hear I can finally it's work you need to
have a booties which work it's Ellen
[Music]
you got to get ready in front of the
public this year what was that
experience like for you I loved it
because all the fans you know all the
people who loved Halloween and everyone
who loves costumes you know I'm sure
those were other people that came by I
don't know but there was a lot of people
that came and waved and took photos and
they could finally see you know what
these amazing makeup artists do for a
living all the time in the movie
industry and normally people don't get
to see this kind of stuff because when
you get done you know for a movie you
know you only see the final results in
the movie but you never really see how
it's being put on and so I thought it
was fun for you know the fans to see how
they put this on over hours and hour and
hours and what it takes like we do this
every year but no only no one ever gets
to see it so I thought oh but this year
round because it's 20 years I do it in
the window and then people could see it
hopefully 20 more years of this
Halloween spectacular yeah we were just
saying that she would I stopped a 20
well he'll do anymore
maybe even for the two of you maybe
we'll go to my world we leave this
planet and we go to my world
[Music]